will you ever slow down yeah okay I'm  simple bro I'm [ __ ] simple I'm high  energy and I'm pumped and I'm excited  and passionate but like none of this  [ __ ] [ __ ] matters like honestly right  like back to the how this [ __ ] show  started why are you not upset because I  don't think I mean anything people are  [ __ ] confused well you know what's  important your family right the reason  people get upset is because they think  there's somebody and I tell people like  did you see what happened to prince  prince really [ __ ] culture meant  something poor guy passes we [ __ ] are  all hurt we give them 24 hours of  flowers and then a week later the  world's spinning right everyone's  walking around getting offended as if  they mean something